je trouve ça mais alors tout est dit des
chaussées des secrets a tancé mets salés
sucrés mais marié mai mais j'ai pas
confiance - ou arrière pensées des gens
vous croyez parce que voilà on est tout
seul on se fait des confidences on dit
des choses plus récents et les gens
pourraient se avoir des idées derrière
la tête
écoutez je vous parie que mal tout
contrat est en vacances oui je sais mais
même sur un go que j'adore si nous
surprenait tous les deux ensemble
ben il aurait des arrière-pensées ils
croiraient que peut-être c'est pas moi
c'est ça
yelle mon mari
je te conseille de réfléchir l'enjeu
faire souffrir les voitures mémo y en
colère cette fille là n'est pas pour toi
ah ça je le sais elle a déjà eu une
autre vie féconde is a man tous les
journaux alors si on le sait pas es tu
ne peux pas me perrin elle est la femme
de ton ami je sais je sens mon coeur
tout déchiré entre l'amour et la
bougeotte et l'iran contient de l'amitié
que je ne veux et partait ne la regarde
pas de trop près chose que j'ai plus
cher je n'ai rien fait
ne pourra jamais les mets à sa chute à
l'épaule de moi pepy sûr de lui me
paumer d'accord s'il ne voit pas
d'inconvénient
je suis innocent
je vais la prendre dans mes bras le tout
c'est normal de thriller n'est pas pour
toi c'est l'une des formes de ton ami
pardon qu'est ce que vous avez dit oui
je suis coincé qu'est ce que vous avez
dit c'est la dernière ça avait très bien
entendu non mais j'ai entendu c'est
l'une des femmes de ton ami c'est sa
maman chérie
quelle époque vivons nous